adieu petit cœur benah non justement à
bientôt non mais à bientôt à bientôt
petit cœur s'il y a plein de bestiol
autour de moi c'est
normal c'est parce que je suis au Muséum
d'histoire naturelle de Paris et que
c'est un peu leur spécialité les
bestiols à vrai dire il possède une des
plus grandes collections de bestiole du
monde là tu penses à une bestiole et ben
c là ils l'ont mais vous êtes-vous déjà
demandé ce qu'ils font là tous ces
squelettes et ces bestioles dans le
formol non et ben nous
[Musique]
oui
donc là on va aller voir des des pièces
qui sont assez uniques le morceau de
peau du mammouth de
liakov au-dessus il y a des morceaux de
de muscles on dirait de la viande séchée
incroable c'est ça ouais c'est du
biltong mais préhistorique et là
on a des échantillons de poil de mamouth
qui était dans la collection de
Cuvier et là on voit surtout la
diversité absolument incroyable
d'espèces que vous gardez là il y a des
zèbres il y a tout en fait on a tous les
vertébrés poissons enien reptil oiseau
mammifère il y a des spécimens qui sont
assez
rares ça ouais c'est un
équidn donc celui il est intact on le
garde généralement pour les
expositions et pour montrer aux jeunes
bah qu'il faut protéger les espèces mais
il y a d'autres spécimenses qui ont
beaucoup
servi tu vois c'est un spécimen qui a
été prélevé en
1869 et tu vois c'est largement disséqué
ah oui lui il a été très très dissqué
ouais on a des ornitorin aussi hein mais
oh un
ornitorin le Muséum de Paris compte
parmi les plus grandes collections
naturalistes du monde mais si vous venez
visiter le musée vous n'en verrez en
fait qu'une infime partie car les
millions de spécimens qui forment cette
incroyable col se trouve en fait sous
nos pieds dans la zoothèque et j'ai eu
la chance d'être accueil par jacqu
cuisin responsable des
[Musique]
collections ok donc il y a quand même
pas mal de Boco ah oui oui là il y a le
résultat de quelques centaines de
d'années de de collecte la démarche
c'est toujours la même depuis plusieurs
milliers d'années en Europe occidentale
c'est-à-dire que notre savoir il procède
par comparaison on va être effectivement
amené à comparer et en disant c'est le
même ou l'autre alors là sur les types
qui nous entourent peut-être tous ne
sont-ils pas des bonnes espèces mais ils
ont tous été sous le regard de quelqu'un
qui a dit ça c'est nouveau on a des
choses aussi anciennes que 1809 par
exemple pour certains certains
spécimennes collecté tel que celui-ci et
puis on va voir des choses la mission du
Capon 1883 c'est simplement séparé de 20
cm alors que dans le temps on a quand
même pratiquement pratiquement un siècle
la plus grosse difficulté en fait c'est
de faire en sorte que ces spécimen
arrive jusqu'à nous pour mener ce combat
contre le temps le centre de recherche
sur la conservation un laboratoire du
CNRS travaille ici au Muséum pour
comprendre ce qui a été fait et ce qui
devra être fait pour permettre à ses
collections de passer aux générations
futures elles pourront comme ça
poursuivre leur mission à savoir nous
aider à connaître et comprendre
l'ensemble du monde
vivant rien que
[Musique]
ça allez on y
va alors qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
dispositif expérimental donc ici on va
essayer d'identifier sans ouvrir le
bocal c'est ça qui est nouveau quel
fluide a été utilisé pour conserver ces
petites chauve-souris c'est pas tout le
temps les mêmes au départ c'était plutôt
de l'éthanol donc un alcool et puis avec
l'apparition du formone on s'aperçut que
c'était pas mal pour préserver les
tissus c'est quand même l'un des buts de
ce genre de collection c'est de
conserver vraiment les tissus comment ça
marche ce dispositif pour savoir ce
qu'il y a comme composition dans le
liquide alors ce dispositif en fait
c'est un spectromètre ramant et
l'avantage de faire ça c'est qu'on va
pouvoir savoir ce qu'on ce qu'on peut
mettre pour remplacer celui qui s'est
évaporé ok parce que ce qu'il faut que
je te dise d'abord c'est que le problème
de conservation principal dans les
collections en fluides c'est
l'évaporation ce serait pas plus facile
d'ouvrir l'échantillon et de prélever un
peu de liquide alors c'est ce qui est
fait la plupart du temps dans les
collections le problème c'est que si tu
fais ça tu mets en danger les personnels
surtout si c'est du formone surtout si
c'est du formone et surtout si tu ne
sais pas ce que c'est et si tu sais pas
ce que c'est parce qu'il y a aussi
quelques liquides qui contiennent des
métaux lourds notamment ou d'autres
choses toxiques la plupart sont assez
toxiques quand même et alors c'est quoi
la meilleure solution ah si on avait
trouvé le Graal ce serait parfait mais
il y en a qui sont meilleurs que
d'autres mais on n pas encore trouvé la
solution parfaite en tout cas le forb
c'est certainement le le fluide qui qui
fixe le mieux les tissus par contre si
c'est l'ADN qu'on regarder on sait que
l'éthanal conserve mieux l'ADN mais
voilà l'autre problème c'est par exemple
l'exposition c'est difficile de mettre
des cuves entières de formol au milieu
d'un musée exposé au public donc c'est
pour ça que il y a encore des recherches
qui sont faites pour remplacer le fluide
dans le cas notamment des expositions ou
en tout cas sécuriser les pièces à
exposer dans les musées face au public
wou qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc
qu'est-ce que alors ce truc c'est un
cœur de rhinocéros c'est un cœur de
rinocéros c'est un cœur de rinocéros qui
a été qui est rentré en collection en
1874 là on voit c'était une étude
sûrement comparative du cœur des Rino
avec je sais pas de l'éléphant de la
vache enfin plein plein d'individus ce
bocal a été réouvert au cours du 20e
siècle parce qu'il est en formol et
comme le formol a été découvert en 1896
en 1874 c'est en alcool ça a été ouvert
courant du 20e siècle pour faire une
dissection et ça a été conservé dans le
formol ou donc les les collections que
vous avez ici elles ont pour but d'être
d'être étudié et pas d'être conservé à
vitam Etam dans le même état il faut
qu'elle puisse aussi être accessible à
la dissection ou sont accessibl à la
dissection c'est une des
caractéristiques de la collection
anatomie comparé mais maintenant avec
les nouvelles techniques d'imagerie
médicale on peut faire une
reconstitution virtuelle de l'animal ou
du cœur et faire une dissection
virtuelle sans être obligé d'intervenir
directement sur la pièce surtout quand
c'est une pièce qui est super rare come
on a des animaux en collection c'est pas
la peine d'aller sur le terrain pour
prélever et donc on va venir ici faire
des prélèvements sur les animaux de
collection d'où l'utilité d'avoir des
collections même historiques qui sont
conservé ici et et celui-là du coup toi
pourquoi tu l'as sorti là aujourd'hui le
couvercle de ce bocal là a été été cassé
donc bah il faut restaurer le bocal et
la pièce qui est dedans donc on a déjà
nettoyé le bocal on a nettoyé le dessus
des lèvres et on va pouvoir remettre un
nouveau couvercle mais avant on a
prélevé le lutage qu' avait été fait à
l'époque qu'on va mettre en sachet et
qui sera ensuite analysé au CRC comme on
le fait depuis quelques années
maintenant donc une fois que vous avez
analysé le liquide qui est à l'intérieur
vous analysez aussi ce qui a servi à
faire le le lutage là le joint
exactement puisque c'est l'élément de
conservation euh le plus critique on a
essayé de regarder quels étaient les
matériaux qui avaient été utilisés par
les anciens euh pour pour savoir ensuite
si certains étaient plus efficaces que
d'autres ils ont aussi peu documenté
cette partie de la préparation et donc
de fait il a fallu déjà retrouver par
l'analyse l'analyse chimique la
composition de de ces systèmes de
fermeture qu'on appelle des lutages dans
ce cas-là et donc dans ce classeur on a
rassemblé les différents prélèvements
avec les différentes études qu'on a
faites dessus et donc comme vous le
voyez il y a des compositions et des
couleurs très différentes et malgré tout
on en a extrait que SEP groupes de
compositions donc contrairement à ce
qu'on pensait au début de cette
recherche la texture la couleur ne
présage pas de la composition chimique
de ces différents Lage sur la
conservation de ces objets l'élément le
plus déterminant et bien c'est le lutage
pourquoi parce que en fait il y a des
interactions entre le spécimen et le
fluide qui peuvent conduire à un
assombrissement du fluide on le voit
très bien ici tout ce qui va être lié à
l'étanchéité du lutage va beaucoup
servir à la conservation et donc c'est
pas juste que l'alcool ne s'évapore pas
mais c'est aussi que l'oxygène ne puisse
pas rentrer exactement c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut éviter tous les transferts
l'évaporation d'alcool parce que on n
pas envie de de refaire les les niveaux
tous les tous les 3 ans donc
l'évaporation d'alcool ou l'évaporation
d'eau ou l'évaporation de de formol et
cetera mais aussi l'entrée d'oxygène
parce que l'oxygène dans le cas par
exemple de du formol peut oxyder la
fonction aldéhide du formol pour en
faire un acide et cet acide généralement
n'est pas très bon pour les spécimes
donc en ayant une meilleure un meilleur
recul de l'histoire des pratiques de
lutage on peut espérer refaire ces
lutages et étudier leur performance et
là c'est ce que vous testez avec ça
c'est le
l'évaporation exactement donc là dans
dans ce système on a une flute modèle
qu'on a reluté on a mis donc on met un
fluide au fond et donc on ferme
l'enceinte et on regarde au fur et à
mesure du temps l'éthanol par exemple si
c'est de l'éthanol on regarde en fait la
concent en fonction du temps et donc là
si on l' fait par exemple pour les
différents silicones on voit qu'à partir
d'un moment on arrive une évaporation
importante de l'éthanol dans dans
l'enceinte et donc ce qui marque une
fuite évidemment dans le dans le système
la question étant au bout de combien de
temps on a cette fuite donc cette étude
cinétique permet ensuite de dire au
gestionnaires de collection au bout de
combien de temps il faudra faire le
suivi des pièces pour pouvoir continuer
à les conserver correctement bon alors
on le referme alors on va compléter avec
du formol
faut que ça aille vraiment jusquen haut
oui il faut qu'on le laisse quelques
centimètres seulement auudessus parce
que si tu as beaucoup d'air tu une
potentielle oxydation plus
importante donc là on va vérifier que
tout est bien propr bien il y a pas
problème d'aspérité il y a pas de gras
surtout parce que sinon ça pourrait
empêcher le form un
problème il y a un reste de l'ancien
lutage alors on va l'enlever parce que
ça va nous
gêner pour remettre le
silicone mais par contre on va garder
ces petites traces que tu vois aussi qui
le lutage historique qui est une une
trace de l'histoire du bocal en
[Musique]
fait direction l'éternité
ou
presque là il a des trucs qui vient de
la nelle Calédonie du du vanoitou ils
sont encore rangés par destination parce
que les expéditions scientifiques
continuent à ramener des échantillons
alors c'est conditionitionné de manière
un peu moins sexy mais ensuite s'est mis
dans des bocons en vert et intégré aux
collections du Muséum pour perpétuer
l'héritage scientifique qui se poursuit
encore
aujourd'hui c'est les mêmes crevettes
que chez
le que Ch le poissonnier là en
conservation un choix c'est toujours un
compromis on peut pas tout avoir on peut
pas avoir la perfection
donc quand on a des collections énormes
à gérer et bien il faut faire des
compromis de ce qui est faisable
réalisable et si la la la la solution
idéale prend beaucoup trop de temps où
on en a pas les moyens et bien on va
utiliser une solution un peu moins
idéale mais qui correspond au moyens
qu'on a auenté mais la collection encore
une fois c'est une archive donc
lorsqu'on a un doute on peut aussi s'y
référer et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on les
garde donc il y a cette valeur
mémorielle quelque part encore une fois
cette valeur d'archive euh et que et
puis une valeur de socle dans le sens où
c'est sur les collections que sont
fondés les savoirs et finalement la
conservation se doit d'être au service
de la de la science parce qu'il faut
qu'elle préserve les échantillons donc
c'est à nous de trouver les solutions
pour que ça puisse se faire l'inventaire
du vivant est loin d'être terminé et de
nouvelles questions émergent à chaque
nouveau projet de recherche et c'est
quand même fou de penser que la
possibilité d'y répondre tient peut-être
à la qualité du joint détancher d'un
vieux bocal en vert en tout cas
l'histoire du vivant que nous raconent
ces collections est sûrement l'une des
plus belles des plus passionnantes et
des plus importantes des histoires à
raconter merci pour l'accueil merci pour
votre temps merci
[Musique]
merci